by the year 2050 the population of
Africa will have doubled one in four
people on earth will be African at that
point now this is both really exciting
and daunting all at once it's really
exciting because for the first time in
the modern era there'll be enough
Africans on the earth to bully everybody
else I'm only kidding but it's daunting
because we're going to have to have
economies that can sustain this
population growth and many of the people
are going to be very young
now most governments in Africa have a
plan for this economic growth in Kenya
we call our vision 2030 and they're all
predicated on industrialization the
thing is though that the world is going
through the fourth Industrial Revolution
right now which means that there's a
merger of the physical cyber and
biological worlds it means that because
of massive interconnectivity and the
availability of artificial intelligence
and robotics many of the jobs that we
know and I used to write now won't exist
in the future so the challenge is a lot
greater in many ways than it even was
when Asia was industrializing for
example to add to this one of the kinds
of per-person that you need for
industrialization as an engineer and
they're really in short supply on the
continent if you compare for example the
number of Engineers that those same
Asian countries had a couple of decades
ago and they were industrialized we're
far we fall far short and I've taught
for a while and many of the students who
were studying engineering end up
actually working in auditing firms and
banks and many of them spend half their
time doing accounting and so on as
they're preparing now I was fortunate
enough to do my undergrad and post-grad
education in the UK in the u.s. in
countries environments where there was
all the equipment that you required all
the sophistication in the systems and
then I worked for about three years in
Japan
doing R&D for a large firm and so I was
very used to having good equipment and
went back home and joined the Faculty of
engineering at the University of Nairobi
wanting to contribute and be on the
continent
and I quickly found I was really quite
useless because there wasn't all the
equipment that I've become accustomed to
available and I was teaching students
who out find very bright ideas in their
minds and they'd be presenting things
that I knew if only we had sufficient
equipment they be able to really
contribute to the to the challenge of
industrialization so I kind of had to
change hats and became quite
entrepreneurial and started looking for
money to buy the equipment that we
required and I heard about a concept out
of MIT called fab labs these are digital
fabrication labs that allow in a rather
small space with not very expensive
equipment people to have access to these
tools to be able to make almost anything
as a slogan goes and so I was able to
convince a government official to buy
one of these for the University where I
was teaching and immediately we had
wonderful results we saw all kinds of
innovations coming through and for the
first time in this context of the
university students from different
disciplines were doing engineering
students that is were doing the lab and
practical exercises together in the same
space normally they'd be siloed and not
just that but students who weren't
engineers at all were also working in
the same space and non-students people
who had nothing to do with the
university were also coming into this
space
so you had this rich mix of people
people who think differently from one
another and this always is really good
for innovation so I was really proud of
what we were seeing happening so you can
imagine my surprise when one day the
Dean of engineering came and said to me
come out the students who spend most of
the time in the Fab Lab are failing
their exams I said what do you mean and
I looked into it and he was right and
the reason they were failing is that
they'd hold their skills so well in
certain things that they were going out
into the city and offering services for
money so they were making money and they
therefore weren't focusing on their
studies and I thought what a good
problem to have
don't quote me on that I'm an
academician so we needed to scale this
and at the university things were a bit
too bureaucratic and so I moved out and
I hooked up with people who in Arabi
were providing spaces for IT experts to
to share fast internet and things like
that and this
these spaces are really quite famous
round they've made Kenya famous for for
IT and together we set up a space which
we're setting up right now we've moved
from where we were in a much larger
space and we're sort of making available
a wide range of equipment including the
digital fabrication tools that I
mentioned and analog tools to anybody
really on a membership basis it's a bit
like a gym so you come in you pay you
get taught how to use the equipment and
then you're set free to innovate and do
whatever you whatever it is that you
want then you don't have to be an
engineer necessarily and some of the
people in the space are setting up a
small company they just need a space at
a desk and so we provide that at a fee
and others take up bigger spaces and are
able to set up their offices that
further along maybe they've got a
company that's been running for a
certain period of time and so we're able
to accommodate all of this in an
innovation space that is really quite
active what you're seeing in this image
over here is Douglas and Douglas is an
electrical engineer one of the people
who was really active in the Fab Lab I
think he passed his exams pretty sure he
did and the image on the top left is a
copper sheet and he designed a circuit
that a client came to him and said I
need this circuit for a pay-as-you-go
system so this is a model for business
that's made accessibility to goods and
service for very poor people really much
easier because they're able to pay a
little bit like a dollar a day for
example for a specific service and so
this company wanted to pilot a new idea
that they have and so they just need 50
circuits so they hired him to make them
and what you're seeing him doing there
is he's able to design on the computer
what the circuit will be and then
transfer it to an etching process that's
at the image on the top right and then
populate the board using this robot and
so what would normally take him maybe a
day or something to to solder by hand
he can do in a few minutes using this
machine so he was able to complete the
entire order within gearbox and this is
really important because if it wasn't
for what we provided right now he would
have had to have hired a company in
China to do this and because it's such a
small order I would have taken a long
time it would be a small company because
big companies wouldn't take small orders
and even then if they got a bigger order
they'd bump him off
in favor of that and there's language
problems and so on so being able to do
it in country is really very important
and of course piloting as a phase within
the the progress of the business idea is
extremely important because you can go
back and make corrections and so on in
in this image thank you in this image
here on the top left what you're looking
at is a 3d render of a digital
fabrication machine in this instance is
a it doubles as a plasma cutter and also
a wood router and so the plasma cutter
makes possible the cutting of a plate
and sheet metal and basically you make a
design on the computer and send it over
to the machine and then very quickly and
precisely it's able to cut the shapes
that you want but in this particular
machine you can also do change the
plasma cutter and put on a spindle and
you can carve wood as well so this was
designed by my head of engineering his
name is rashida and when I hired him
about two years ago I asked him just
give me two years and by the time you've
trained a lot of people so we have good
stuff under you then you can move out
and become a good story for our space
and that's exactly what's just happened
he's got two types of customers the
higher tier customer is a company that's
actually using his machine to cut sheet
metal for Isuzu truck fabrication in
Aerobie which is being done by General
Motors so we're really proud to be able
to say that we have an original
equipment manufacturer in Nairobi that's
provided what's effectively an
industrial robot to supply parts for
General Motors now this is really
important and it's really important
because the population growth being what
it is a lot of very large companies are
looking very closely at the market
that's developing in Africa so in Kenya
right now we have Volkswagen pusher read
know we have Mercedes doing lorries and
we've also got Toyota they've been there
a long time and these are all
manufacturers planning to assemble
vehicles and in the future to
manufacture in the country many of them
are planning to train lots of people
that they'd hire and that's really
important for the economy but when when
the magic really happens when these
companies begin to buy their parts they
need for the other vehicles from local
companies so supply chain development is
something that's very important for us
to be able to pivot and
have very productive economies and
that's something we're focused on at our
space this other image shows another
class of customer that he has on the top
left you have these people who are
actually using very crude tools to work
metal and wood and Kenya has a
population of about 44 million people
the workforce is about 13 million and
about 80 to 90 percent of those are in
the informal sector and what you see in
the image on the top left over there is
very typical of semi skilled people
artisans who are making products for the
marketplace that are really crude their
production rate is really very slow the
quality of the product isn't high and so
we've teamed
Ouachita up with a bank and the bank is
paying him to train people from this
sector on how to use this industrial
robot and the result is that they're
going to some of them are going to be
able to get loans to buy the machine for
themselves others will be able to go to
centers where they can carry their
material get the design done and take
the material the materials back that
have been made really really fast and
assemble them in their own spaces so
somebody making a gate for example out
of metal may take a week to make just
one gate but with this machine they
might might make 10 in a day so the
productivity of a large swath of our
population should be able to jump by a a
quantum amount quite significantly
because of this kind of machine and
that's what we're at the beginning of so
this is really very exciting this is
another person who uses our space her
name is Esther she's in her mid-20s and
she came in very passionate about a
problem that she explained she said that
school days are missed every month by
young girls because of their menstrual
cycle and they're not able to buy a
sanitary towel and the reason that she
described was that the manufacturers
packaged these in bundles of seven to
ten and breaking it down is unhygenic
at the retail level and packaging each
one of them is too expensive
so she thought up an idea which is
brilliant and simple why don't we just
use vending machines and she in a in a
very clean environment can break down
the bundles and fill up the the vending
machines and then girls can buy these
sanitary sanitary towels in the privacy
of a toilet in a public space in the
school and so what she was able to pilot
this and it worked really very well
and she's been able to sort of get the
bugs out and so on so the significance
here is that the piloting process is
being possible she's not an engineer she
was able to engage people in our space
to be able to help her to do this and
she's often running now with a Business
Accelerator so we expect to see great
results in this image you're looking at
the result of a master's project that
was done at university of nairobi by
tony nada an engineering student and he
just integrated a solar cell into a roof
tile and decided to make it a business
and he joined up with his sister who is
an architect and they have this business
and they come and present the roof tile
to a person who is doing development and
say you can take this and buy it for the
cost of just a roof tile without the
solar so they're giving it at a discount
and then they'll build them using the
internet of things over time and they'll
pay about a third of what the utility
charges for the electricity and they can
sell the excess back to the grid and so
they'll make their money over time and
they've been able to do quite a few
installments we were very proud to be
able to show this to somebody kind of
famous as you can see there and this
other famous guy actually presented the
same idea but as far as we're concerned
it was after us so
so in closing going forward of course
being able to prototype and do low
manufacturing in this kind of a setting
is very important for the
industrialization process but we're also
taking advantage of a lot of new ways of
doing things the open source movement
distributed manufacturing circular
production - it's all very important for
not just being industrializing and being
able to meet people's needs but also
making sure that the environment is
taken care of we're also really very
interested in culture we have lots of
discussions in our space around who we
were as Africans who we are today and
who we want to be these are V things
like consumerism and ethnicity and
corruption and so on so we see ourselves
as providing adding value to people by
teaching them to add value to things or
materials so that they can build things
that matter thank you very much for your